EPIK I will be lovers it's Jan here in
this video I want to talk about a quiet
place and some intriguing deleted scenes
and rejected concepts Plus how the
creature design changed over the course
of production if you're finding me for
the first time I do lots of movie
deleted scenes and breakdown so do
subscribe if you enjoy this obviously
spoilers ahead for the movie so take
care if you haven't seen it yet the
movies producers have revealed the
original script included flashbacks in
fact initially the loss of the family's
youngest son was going to be handled in
a flashback
however when director and star John
Krasinski did his rewrite of Bryan Woods
and Scott Beck's script he wanted to
make that shocking moment feel more
urgent so he cut the flashback brought
the scene into the present and moved it
right up to the front of the movie
losing that flashback and shifting the
scene to the start of the film was a
great call by christiansí as it made the
terrifying reality of the family
situation totally clear from the get-go
basically the unthinkable becomes all
too imaginable for both the family and
the audience other flashbacks which
featured the characters talking were
also given the Trop by Krasinski though
the producers weren't specific in their
hollywood reporter interview I think the
deleted dialogue may well have filled in
some of the abbot's backstory as well as
background about the invasion of the
creatures speaking of backstory in the
trailer there was a scene which was
deleted from the film which shows emily
Blunt's character evelyn watching what
looks like news footage on various
monitors and there are also voiceovers
from different news reports
[Music]
this looks like it was probably part of
some early exposition about the alien
invasion which ended up being cut from
the movie what's also interesting in
this deleted scene is that this version
of the father's whiteboard wasn't
actually in the film according to this
board there were three creatures to
start and that increased to five but in
the final film the whiteboard clearly
shows that there are only 3 confirmed
creatures in the area and at the end of
the movie Evelyn kills one of those and
we see two others on the monitors as
they approach the house I imagine the
filmmakers reduce the number of monsters
in the area as they wanted to leave the
ending more realistically hopeful for
the family and if they'd had four
creatures left to kill at once their
odds would have been significantly
slimmer while including more background
about the Abbott's and the invasion in
the film could have been interesting
personally I liked the way we were
dropped into the family's daily life in
the middle of this apocalyptic situation
without getting uh doors of exposition
airy dialogue about the characters or
creatures backgrounds while you could
never accuse John Krasinski's film of
being overly wordy the draft screenplay
for a quiet place only had three words
of dialogue in it in that early script
the characters communicated via gestures
and hand motions but it wasn't until
precints key came on board to direct
star and rewrite that the idea of using
American sign language was included in
the film along with a cochlear implant
being the key to the creatures defeat
these changes made a huge impact on the
final movie especially since christiansí
pushed to cast deaf actress Millicent
Simmons as his on-screen teen daughter
Regan Simmons injected her real-life
experience of deafness into the film
teaching the cast sign language onset
and advising Krasinski on several key
moments for their characters for
instance she told Metro that the scene
where Krasinski's character Lee argues
with Regan after he stops her going into
the basement was initially going to play
out rather differently with Regan
backing down to her father's authority
however during filming Simmons suggested
her character would actually be
rebellious in that moment and christen
ski and bracelet idea hole
but idli also originally before lease
sacrifice at the end he was only going
to sign I love you to his children
however Simmons proposed a subtle but
very effective change which was for Lita
also signed I have always loved you
as Regan's brother told his father
earlier in the film Regan felt her dad
blamed her for the death of her little
brother and no longer loved her though
that wasn't the case so thanks to the
additional signing Lee's final moments
see him act on his sons earlier
suggestion to tell Regan what he feels
for her and that really heightened the
emotional impact of Leaves fate while
mending his strained relationship with
his daughter all of which was a great
addition to the final film the original
design for the creatures was very
different to what we see in the film
according to visual effects supervisor
Scott Farrar initially the monsters
looked much less imposing and had
rhinoceros style horns on their faces
they were actually well into
post-production when Ferrara and John
Krasinski realized that the creatures
needed a complete redesign as they just
weren't frightening enough in fact when
they placed them in the movie they
looked a little silly Farrar suggested
taking the VFX in a totally different
direction going for something that
looked as he told Vanity Fair much more
gross really medical and raw of course
silence and sound were always at the
heart of the film so getting the right
look for the creatures ears was crucial
and that was also altered a number of
times during production with the
monsters hearing canals being moved
around the body from the chest to the
head elsewhere and back again for the
final design of the aliens though the
filmmakers looked to real life for
inspiration including a sea creature
with very poor eyesight called the
Nautilus bats snakes prehistoric fish
and even bog bodies which are human
corpses mummified in peat reading
through your comments on my ending and
creatures explained video I noticed some
of you had issues with details in the
movie that you felt creative plot holes
one of which was to do with the family's
electricity supplying now it's
interesting you brought that up because
in an interview with slash film
screenwriters Scott Beck and Brian woods
have said that as they were writing they
did think through the logic of many
different aspects of the film's premise
and have answers to a good
those questions their draft script
explained lots of those details such as
how the abbot's got their electricity
through generators placed underground so
they didn't make any noise above ground
I think such details were dropped from
the final film as director and co-writer
John Krasinski felt they weren't crucial
to the overall movie and wanted to
concentrate on creating interesting
character moments and interactions while
ratcheting up the tension throughout and
still keep the runtime to a tight 90
minutes I'm sure you can think of more
than a few movies you've seen yourself
with scenes that have bogged down in
exposition and over explaining
themselves but co-writer Brian Webb said
that they really wanted to slowly paint
in the world these characters are living
in by showing us the newspaper headline
here and there or an awkward
conversation at the family dinner table
as Woods has also said I think you can
make assumptions and give the finished
film the benefit of the doubt before the
movie was released there was a theory
doing the rounds online for a while that
a quiet place was going to be part of
the Cloverfield universe and when the
writers beckoned woods pitched the movie
to the studio they did initially fear
that Paramount which also distributes
the Cloverfield movies might try and
make the film fit into that franchise I
can see the mysterious alien monsters in
the movie could potentially have been
incorporated into the Cloverfield
mythology however I'm glad paramount
shared the writers view that a quiet
place was strong enough to stand on its
own two feet and if there are quiet
place equals or anthology films the
producers don't intend for there to be
any crossover with Cloverfield in the
future either speaking to cinema blend
Andrew form and Brad Fuller said that's
not our world that's JJ's world and is
carefully curating that I think John
Krasinski has created this amazing world
with his characters and I think a quiet
place definitely lives on its own
although the movie does of course lean
into horror tropes I think it managed to
create something that felt fresh and was
riveting to watch the writers have
already said they already have a number
of ideas and set pieces that they didn't
end up using in the film so it would be
interesting to see what they come up
with for a follow up now what do you
think about the changes in cutscenes in
a quiet place
what were your favorite moments in the
movie and what would you like to see
happen in a sequel let me know below and
you can also tweet me at Jan underscore
Gilbert or at
like city if you enjoyed this leave a
thumbs up and tap the screen here for
more amazing movie deleted scenes and
breakdowns thanks for watching and see
you next time you be gay movie lovers